you know it's very strange to me that
someone going through menopause
would have to suffer with
pot flashes night sweats vaginal dryness
decreased libido anxiety depression I
mean that's just weird and we're told
that these symptoms are normal it's part
of life we just have to cope with it and
accept it because your sex hormones
naturally decrease with age
by a factor of at least 50 percent
because you're no longer having
functional ovaries anymore right so the
question is is this true and the answer
is no it's absolutely false information
when you go through menopause you have
two backup organs they're called the
adrenals and the adrenals make all of
the hormones that the ovaries make okay
all these sex hormones
estrogen progesterone testosterone
and they make a lot of other hormones
too like cortisol aldosterone
DHEA things like that so the way it's
supposed to work is during menopause
you have a decreased ovarian function
and the adrenals are supposed to back it
up and start making these hormones and
no it's not normal to have any symptoms
when you're going through menopause so
what is the problem okay well take a
look at this chart right here we have a
chart of the metabolic pathways through
the adrenals the different layers of the
adrenal and the different hormones that
are created by your adrenals you have
mineral corticoids glucocorticoids
Androgen estrogen all of these hormones
stem from this one thing this one raw
material check it out right here
cholesterol that's right the very thing
that people are telling you to avoid
because it causes heart disease right so
at the expense of lowering cholesterol
through the diet a diet recommendation
or medication
boy are your adrenals gonna suffer
because that cholesterol is a required
material to not only make all of your
sex hormones
and all of the adrenal hormones that are
on the outside called the cortex and
also cholesterol is the absolute
required material to make vitamin D
and you know how important that is also
to make bile salts to help you digest
fat to make sure you have enough vitamin
A d e k and also to supply your brain do
you realize that 25 of your brain is
cholesterol in fact certain cells in the
brain these are support cells they're
not neurons they're called glial cells
make cholesterol so 75 of all the
cholesterol in your body right now is
made by your own cells not just by the
brain cells but other cells as well only
25 percent comes from the diet and you
might be saying well I do eat a lot of
fat in my diet I have my olive oil I
have my soy oil my canola oil I have my
avocado oil I'm consuming my coconut oil
really well guess what there is no
cholesterol in plants or plant oils or
seed oils cholesterol only comes from
animal products and I want to emphasize
that a 80 percent of the cholesterol
that feeds the adrenals is in the form
of LDL that so-called bad cholesterol
that we have to avoid so by cutting out
cholesterol from the diet or using
medication that lowers the cholesterol
there is all these Cascade problems all
this collateral damage that can occur
including the big ones of menopausal
symptoms depression anxiety loss of
memory I mean if you think about even
one of the side effects of statins which
is a medication to block your production
of cholesterol one of the symptoms is
called transient global amnesia okay you
have certain times where you just lose
your memory when you're on statins you
actually increase the risk of cancer
people with higher cholesterol have
lower incidence of cancer so apparently
there's this cholesterol immune system
relationship now that could be because
the vitamin D or other factors and we
all know the common symptoms from being
on a Statin is muscle pain and muscle
problems because of what it does to
something called coenzyme Q10 okay
that molecule is blocked when you take
statins and That's essential for
allowing your mitochondria to use fat as
fuel so it's intimately involved in the
production of energy especially in your
muscles and so if you starve off the
muscle from getting energy you get all
sorts of problems and this is one of the
biggest side effects and reasons why
people stop taking statins as the side
effect of lowering cholesterol and so if
we take a broad look at all the symptoms
that women go through during menopause
they all relate to a deficiency of sex
hormones and what many women don't
realize is the vital importance of just
supporting this cholesterol to feed
these hormones to make sure they have
the raw material and what you're going
to find out if you make just a slight
change in your diet is the very dramatic
and sudden disappearance of these
menopausal symptoms just by increasing
more more cholesterol in the diet and
now you know why because all of these
hormones are built from cholesterol so
start adding more cholesterol to the
diet and the number one food that can
actually help you is high quality
grass-fed butter that's right start
putting it in your coffee start putting
it in your food don't be afraid to
consume real butter and again realize
that you can't get your cholesterol from
plants so all these other oils okay
which are fine like olive oil is fine
some of these other oils like avocado is
fine but it's not going to help you
build up your adrenal hormones and by
the way the more stress that your body
goes through especially during Menopause
the more cholesterol you need especially
more LDL now the key to this to make
sure that this LDL doesn't end up being
the wrong type of LDL because there's
two different kinds is this as you
increase your dietary fat you also at
the same time time want to reduce your
carbohydrates because you never want to
consume a high sugar high carb diet with
a high fat diet as long as you keep your
carbs low as in the ketogenic diet you
can consume higher amounts of this fat
so butter is number one you might want
to add some fatty cheese like brie
cheese I would recommend grass-fed don't
be afraid to add cream like I get my raw
cream every week from a local Farm egg
yolks another important source of
cholesterol so Seafood Oregon meats are
all awesome to help support your
adrenals and do not do lean proteins
okay don't do low fat anything because
more lean the protein is like even
protein powders you're going to
stimulate more insulin the fat helps
buffer the protein on the insulin index
because if you keep the insulin down
you're going to be protected now during
this process it may be helpful to add
vitamin D as well as purified bile salts
to help you digest this fat I'm not
saying go crazy with unlimited amounts
of fat I'm just saying that if you are
on a low-fat diet I'm talking about low
animal fats you need to start increasing
it and if you have a hard time digesting
it chances are you probably don't have
enough bile salts add those to the mix
so you can digest it and you might just
be very pleasantly surprised that your
menopausal symptoms magically disappear
now if you have not seen my video
um the difference between the two
different ldls this is a very important
video to watch and I put that video up
right here check it out